hi i'm christopher hine and today we're
going to be making a video talking about
the third of the classical weapons in
aikido so if you've been setting aikido
very long you probably know that there
are three classical weapons we talk
about the joe the bokeh and the tonto
but if you've done aikido for any length
of time and you've seen a fair amount of
the syllabus for most schools of aikido
there's a fair amount of joe work
there's a fair amount of bokeh work but
there's hardly any tanto work and so
you're probably saying
what where is all this tanto work that
supposedly we do because it's not
comparable in syllabus to the boken and
the joe the truth is everything we do in
aikido is actually tonto work and i'm
gonna get josh over here and we're going
to talk about how that looks today i'm
going to show you some popular aikido
techniques and i'm going to show you how
that's actually a tonto technique in one
way or another someone called joshua
here we're going to go to work josh
all right so let's talk about the tonto
techniques in aikido and in the teaser i
said that all the techniques are tonto
techniques and that's really really true
and that's true because you have to
understand that all the techniques in
aikido's technical syllabus for kumiuchi
struggling methods are built around
jiu-jitsu and jiu-jitsu is built around
small arms work so you can use slightly
larger arms work so of course you could
use spears and you could use swords
which are slightly longer but but really
the idea of jiu-jitsu is we're in close
and we're struggling over small weapons
little weapons like knives okay
a lot of the times when you see aikido
techniques if you think they're unarmed
techniques it will be confusing and if
you understand that there are techniques
it will not be confusing and a lot of
times i think when i say that people say
well there really aren't that many armed
techniques in aikido every technique is
a small arms technique and i'll show you
what i mean so let's look at the basic
attacks we start from right so the
shomonucci position actually let's go to
this side the shomonuchi position is a
super common position to start from in
aikido it's one of the most common
positions okay now that's super
utilitarian position because if this guy
was attacking me with a small arm
overhead like cutting me or stabbing me
bang like that okay and i did this we
are now in the shomanucci position this
is a super common thing to happen let's
say i need to use a knife on this guy
when i come down and he defends we are
in the shomonuchi position so the
shomonucci position is a position seen a
lot nike though because when you have a
small thing in your hand that you're
coming down at them with right and that
of course could be anything but a knife
is is is like the ultimate small thing
right so it's it's better than a rock or
a little stick because it does more work
than those things so the ultimate small
object is definitely dealt with in that
shomanucci fashion okay now what about
yokomanuchi now when we see it unarmed
of course this looks kind of dumb to us
but when you realize if i'm going like
this and cutting that carotid that's all
of a sudden a very sensible technique
right so when he comes in with that what
do i do i do this which really is just
an inside variation of this so if he's
coming outside like that we look like
this if he's coming inside we look like
this so look at these positions right
this is also why we don't formally talk
about yaku yokomin so regular yokemen's
this boom gyaku yokemen's this but gyaku
yokemen when i defend that is a showman
position
versus if it's a regular yokelman it's a
new position it's a slightly different
position we see from this right so this
is again a weapon technique all right
now what about ski so ski it's okay ski
is a big dumb punch right so so who
punches like that no one but understand
in the aikido syllabus i'm always trying
to switch the other hand for me i'm
always trying to stay away from this guy
and so ideally he's getting super
frustrated and he'll lunge in and that
lunge in is what sets up all of those
kinds of techniques from ski so our
three strikes are weapon strikes they're
tonto strikes small arms strikes showman
yokomin and ski and that's why we have
that set up for techniques okay now
let's look at all the wrist grabbing
stuff right so if uh actually yeah we'll
have him so josh is gonna be uh the nage
so in this if i grab this guy like this
because he's gonna stab me there's our
katate dory if he switched and i
switched there's our yakute dory if i
tried to take advantage of this and go
two on one there's our morote door if he
switched again i go over and i don't
want him to keep switching there's a
ryote door and you can see the
progression and i've made videos on this
before so i want you to see that those
attacks all exist because there's a
small arm in play so all of the aikido
attacks come from small arms now what
about the actual techniques themselves
right so let's get into a technique
let's look at the technique for
shomonucci ikiyo
tewaza all right now if this guy's got
the knife and he comes in here what do i
want to do well i would like to get this
guy away if i have a superior weapon so
if i bump him here and can draw my
weapon there we see how the technique of
ikyo multi is immediately used for this
knife what about ikyoura we come in and
i try to bump him and he's too strong so
i go behind him in order to draw my
weapon and use my weapon so there again
we're seeing small arms used there are
two of the classic techniques we see in
aikido that come from that okay now what
if this guy were or sorry what if um
this guy wore two i was to use the knife
on this guy and sorry i'm trying to
figure out the best angle so here i come
up here and i he defends me like this
what do i want to do well i want to
control this arm so i can get in here
and stab him with this one
what if he grabs my hand so i can't get
in there and stab him well i push him
down so i can get him into a position to
take him to take my weapon out right and
that could go all the way down to the
ground where he's got a hold of me so i
can't use that weapon right what if i'm
going to draw my weapon here and he
grabs my hand like this again here's our
echo but what if i can't get his hand up
because he's too strong well now we see
all of these outside techniques like our
coat of guys because when he comes
around not only does he get kodagaish
but he gets cut as well
so every single technique we do in
aikido we can do with a weapon in our
hands and it will make them more natural
than it is unarmed so when you see them
armed you'll go oh yeah of course these
are the logical progressions you should
make however
when we see them unarmed you go why did
you grab that way and why did he hit
that way and then why is he moving that
direction and what's going on there
there's a lot of confusion when you see
it without the weapon but when you
instantly understand that all techniques
in aikido are based around a knife or a
greater weapon then you say oh i see why
the tanto is one of the three weapons
included in aikido so i hope this helped
you guys there are several tricky
techniques out there and if you find any
leave it in the comments below and i'll
show you how it actually works because
you will find a few techniques that it
doesn't make any sense because you'll
try i recommend everyone try all these
all their techniques with a knife in
their hand and there's a few that you're
going to try and you're going to say oh
this is kind of weird this doesn't work
out right leave a comment below because
there's about four pretty big ones
popular ones that you'll find weird and
i'll explain those once you find them
i'm christopher hines this is joshua
tihi myself mcdaniels behind the camera
thanks for watching
[Music]